there's a lot of different herbs and
remedies out there that create effects
okay maybe multiple effects
but berberine takes it to the next level
berberine is a chemical that comes from
different plants and it's most known for
its effect on blood sugars lowering your
blood sugars
helping to make insulin more sensitive
attacking insulin resistance okay which
by the way is at the heart of most
health problems including a fatty liver
high blood pressure high triglycerides
including oxidative LDL which actually
creates a lot of damage on the inside
layer of your heart and berberine has a
very powerful potent effect directly on
the interior wall of your arteries
called the endothelial layer so it can
suppress that oxidation that's happening
that's creating plaquing so it actually
helps shrink lacking and anything that
helps insulin resistance is going to
shrink your midline your weight
circumference berberine has
anti-thrombotic effects it improves the
symptoms of Alzheimer's which is Type 3
diabetes and it greatly improves the
dawn phenomena where you would wake up
in the morning with your blood sugars
too high because you have severe insulin
resistance which is really a problem
with
gluconeogenesis which is the production
of new glucose from other things like
protein and fats just think about a
diabetic right they have high blood
glucose and you might think that the
only reason their blood sugars are high
is because they're eating too many carbs
but that's not 100 True one big reason
why their blood sugar is high is because
their liver is making a lot of new sugar
it's called gluconeogenesis because
they're insulin resistance is so bad and
this is why berberine is equivalent to
metformin okay the main medication they
use in type 2 diabetes but without the
toxic effects now let's get into some
other things that berberine can do it
can activate vitamin D conversion to the
active form when you take vitamin D or
converting sunlight in your skin level
or you're converting your own Vitamin D
from the Sun it has to be converted to
the active form well guess what
berberine helps at conversion berberine
helps prevent cardiac muscle
fibrosis from occurring after a heart
attack or any type of damage involving a
lack of oxygen called ischemia so it's
very protective against the cardiac
muscles from getting the scar tissue
berberine is also a neural protective if
there is toxicity in the neurons
berberine can help protect the neurons
berberine has a really fascinating
effect with neurotransmitters too I'm
talking about dopamine talking about
serotonin noradrenaline
in the hippocampus so it has a direct
Improvement on your mood increasing your
mood from depression or anxiety to a
normal mood berberine even helps the
withdrawal side effects from coming off
of a drug berberine is also very
antimicrobial
anti-viral
antibacterial as well as having a
capacity to improve your immune system
specifically your T cells but out of all
that the real cool thing about berberine
is it can actually reverse mitochondrial
damage improving more oxygen consumption
ATP production electron chain transport
which basically is the conversion of
fuel to ATP and all the different stages
that occur it's like the assembly line
in the machine in the mitochondria that
helps you make energy as well as
increasing the number of mitochondria
but other than that I don't think
berberine has any other
positive effects that I can think of now
this is all really great and interesting
but unless your diet is correct
um you're never going to fully get rid
of insulin resistance and for that
information you should watch this video
right here